[Music]
her only drain tattoo is based on the
books by Stieg Larsson and in those
books your character Elizabeth is a
redhead yeah you guys didn't go that way
in the movie so much well no she's a
redhead but she dyes her hair black
right yes
which is yeah it was very important to
me because I was a follower of the book
you want to be true to the books yes
but obviously there's no way to really
depict that in a movie except that um I
had to wear Merkin do you know American
is Andy knows what American is I'm one
of ya I do know what American is a
merkin is kind of a wig for for down
below yes it's a it's a wig for your
lady bits this interviews over
so you wore one of those for that movie
yeah I mean they didn't they didn't ask
me to but I'm naked so much in it I
wanted one cuz it felt like a little fur
bikini
I'm feeling like such a perv now
tell me more about the fur bikini
my god thank you it was a cute little
fur bikini and I had them make it
strawberry blonde oh okay
that does that's something that you that
you give that back when you're done or
do you know I have it you have it okay
okay that's good you want to keep that a
lot of creeps on eBay yeah you are very
I always pick on me